ce n'est pas le moment de baisser la
garde pour la 17e semaine consécutive la
fin du shabbat Tel Aviv a vu les rues du
centre-ville prise d'assaut
Raquel son mari et leurs trois jeunes
enfants n'ont manqué aucun des
rendez-vous
pour notre avenir c'est une évidence que
de venir l'autre jour ma fille s'est
fait demander à l'école ce qu'elle
voulait t'offrir à son pays pour ses 75
ans et il a répondu la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
ce n'était pas la plus grande des
mobilisations que le pays est connu
depuis quatre mois mais les opposants
projets de réforme judiciaire reste
vigilants la suspension de la réforme ce
n'est pas une victoire
je ne crois pas le gouvernement d'Iron
je ne crois pas le premier ministre ça
ne changera pas venir manifester c'est
la moindre des choses que je puisse
faire pour mon pays sinon ce ne sera
plus mon pays
tout ce processus de destruction de la
démocratie d'éliminer les contrôles et
l'équilibres à deux objectifs titel
d'abord c'est pour que le premier
ministre échappe à la prison ensuite
c'est pour que les ailés et les racistes
qui sont au gouvernement et tout le
pouvoir d'adopter n'importe quelle loi
sans que l'on puisse résister
la crise que traverse le pays se prépare
depuis des décennies et il est beaucoup
plus identitaire que démocratique croit
cette sociologue une espèce de division
qui se fait au niveau de du public
libéral israélien de gauche comme de
droite d'un côté et en public non
libéral qui veut avancer une vision de
la société plus religieuse plus
conservatrice du point de vue des
valeurs et qui veut pousser de manière
générale la place de la religion
vis-à-vis de l'État au sein de l'État
israélien
dans cet océan d'Azur et de blanc
suspendus au dessus des têtes quelques
drapeaux palestiniens et les couleurs
arc-en-ciel de la fierté offert le porte
chaque semaine depuis le début des
manifestations
je les connais bien mais je crois qu'il
faut tu ne séparation nous avons aussi
des musulmans au pays nous avons des
chrétiens et des groupes comme ceci
dit-il en montrant le drapeau de la
fierté il faut veiller sur eux aussi
les organisateurs de la manifestation
appel à observé ce qu'ils ont appelé un
jour national de l'égalité jeudi
prochain il ne peut y avoir de
démocratie sans égalité ont-ils dit
les grands absents de cette
manifestation ce sont les parties
d'opposition sur la même qui en ce
moment cherche à négocier une solution
de compromis avec le gouvernement de
Benyamine Netanyahou pour les gens
rassemblés ici c'est aussi bien ils
veulent envoyer un message clair à tous
les partis politiques confondus vous ne
nous représentez plus et si Marie-Ève
Bédard Radio-Canada Tel Aviv